Thanksgiving is a slasher film set in
Plymouth Massachusetts Thanksgiving is
an institution here they have such a
rich history with the pilgrims it's the
John car a mask first governor of New
Plymouth colon I mean the most that
happened in the town before this was a
parking ticket and now there's a killer
on the loose we're looking for an
individual you're not going to believe
what he's wearing everyone in Town's
wearing them it's fun and it makes you
want to find out who is the killer be
careful who you trust because this is a
matter of life and death the killer is
someone with an axe dressed like a
pilgrim killing people longer this goes
the more Twisted it gets every weapon
he's using is straight off a
Thanksgiving table it's the classic
slasher movie but bigger and more
real I want to create a movie that is so
exciting and terrifying that at every
Thanksgiving dinner someone brings it
up